through these text messages it seals of
course it is why why wouldn't it be
so you said oh here it is
could I just but but you also do
something in Mantid that people do that
you send like four text messages
thoughts thoughts instead of just one
big one because people don't read the
whole one well I didn't read this one
either but I was because I had reached
out to give you my number so I'd like
you to be in my pockets and then you
wrote I said you have a worst birthday
you went oh yes by the way I've been
taking tennis lessons tell me about it
let's talk about it now it's better on
here any literally I know two things
about you oh three you're tall there we
go yes I mean handsome oh and tennis
tennis okay
yes yeah and I was like oh cause I mean
I started like well I think we met
though met we met I think we maybe met
in New York we did you have a New York
thing yeah do you live there I moved
here like a year and a half for the true
show no I just was like I'm done with
all oh yeah I'm done with the [ __ ] [ __ ]
I used those the Monday night show at
the stand called more antic yes and that
I've done friend yes I you know what
that show was so fun I met like
everybody because of that well and it
was just like Monday nights in New York
are not even popping like that so it's
like boom yeah and for first four months
of that show
no one ever showed up and then right at
the end it just was slammed yeah it's
great when I did that show I remember it
being poppin Ehrenburg host that show
now hello Aaron what's your tell me
about your tennis situation what's going
on with it I had to do this like
advertising retreat with truTV there we
go um it was like 60 people goes so like
all the executives some talent
advertisers for the record I was one of
two black people here we go ah oh where
where was it in San Diego at some like
fancy-schmancy spa and I never I mean I
watch tennis on my life I'd never played
and then we had to like take a tennis
lesson yeah and I was like oh [ __ ] this
is
what did you dig it and I'm like good
I'm sure you're good because I was an
athlete I was a gymnast I wasn't at all
[ __ ] were you yes I was a competitive
gymnast so like once you are a gymnast
you can kind of do anything I feel like
gymnasts do not it's once every four
years they get respect because of the
Olympics but that that is full-body grow
and I year-round training that is just
you [ __ ] are it's a beast
I mean six days a week yeah six hours a
day where did you grow up and where did
you train
I I was born here I looked at I was
eight when I grew up in Orlando and
that's where I trained okay at Orlando
metro go Metro what up Metro and once I
gymnast all of the gymnast yeah so what
was your specialty I mean I did all four
events but I was a bars master for real
yeah do you ever hop on the bars KITT
whatever and do that so whenever I go
home for Christmas like we all have a
reunion and we go to gym and we try and
remember [ __ ] I mean I can still tumble
like I can still do a flip what are the
four events in let actually may I try to
guess first please yeah so this is
women's event yes after bad of us the
kicker yeah don't forget floor routine
balance beam mm-hmm bars but what kind
of virus uneven bars Wow there we go
but anything I may have gained by the
third I've lost by the fourth okay horse
no that's not gonna give you I was gonna
give you a clue give me a clue please
it's you playing along at home I hope
you are it's um it requires a
springboard
oh yeah the launch pad that's what I
call no the carries the famous carries
yeah the vault the vault and men are
rings floor pommel horse vault mm-hmm
delicate and is it more firm mm-hmm they
have six events for God's sake is that
equal Amanda exactly I think men should
do five and women should do five it's
that's very good compromise right what
do you make you I don't know why derived
on Twitter you're not afraid of any
topic I'm not I don't know why we don't
I mean I think
that you know a lot of these things are
created so long ago when there was just
this concept of like women aren't strong
enough and it's like we birth a person
we we really hate water sighs hole I
feel like we can handle a fifth event I
agree
but men the thing is like men's events
are considered like strength oven yeah
and women's events are considered
artistic senescence yeah so like men
have like you said they have vault
pommel horse floor high bar high bar
rings rings and then parallel bars hair
oh yeah that's my least favorite but
that's the hardest is it really what
pommels of the hardest barrel is a
second so even if I just hold my arms
out for a minute like this I'll get
tired and these mothers I mean all
gymnasts
but now here's here's a question and
this is why I love doing this pockets
because I learn about my guests and like
we're now we're talking about gymnastics
which I love there are physical
differences in the gender bodies
of course of course so do women want to
do rings and would that even be
interesting I kind of liked it there's
different events no I do I do like
there's different events I feel like
women should have a fifth event that's
not necessarily the same event as men I
agree I think that'd be cool and I'm
down with that
I mean you know in tennis which is my
sport and was how we start talking about
this in the Grand Slams men play three
out of five sets and then played two out
of three and a lot of the male ego is
saying well why are they getting paid
the same when we're playing two out of
five but then I love Serina who's like
all play three out of five let's bring
that [ __ ] up
but the problem is only Serina in a
select handful hand handful yeah could
do that you think well the rest of the
field would need to catch up which is
why everyone Olympics gymnastics changes
their code of points oh and it forces
the sport to get harder to evolve to
evolve all of us so then people are four
clearly for that like there's stuff that
gymnasts are doing now that ten years
ago is just not even conceivable you
look at the track times as well it's
like yes that was considered
scientifically impossible and now it's a
right form if you don't do this yeah
you're not even close
the women's field in tennis is not as
fit but you better [ __ ] gets it
that's good I feel yeah I I'm down with
you on that and I think we'll probably
start to see that I think we're doing a
pretty good job in this country not
saying we're perfect but we got some
other countries that are still making
women just we're [ __ ] like only see
their eyeballs in [ __ ] but a lot of
those women are making that choice too
so we can't do it or go
we can't go say that but I feel like
they're there I feel like the burka is
the least okay the least issue are going
to be worried yeah yeah yeah it does
it's it's the more so the concept of why
because some women wear it because
they're like I don't want to show my
body and my deal with God sure but some
women are wearing it because if they
don't they'll get killed or if they
sleep with someone else they are allowed
to be killed yes and everybody yeah and
so you know damn that's some [ __ ] but
then we are in a country where I feel
like that could that's not that far
fetch you think you're watching the hand
man I was just about this show is
killing it right now you won the Aaron
do you know what it know Aaron's not
it's ruining my life don't you watch
we're talking about The Handmaid's Tale
and right now we're recording this in
May so we're kind of on Episode six or
seven right now okay so when this when
this airs who knows where we'll be but
why why are you responding
why is everybody responding to the show
with such intensity I think it's very
visceral because we're seeing just like
the reality of how backwards our country
is and we didn't think it could happen
within the show they're like that's a
sentiment that gets echoed a lot like
wow we didn't think it could go this far
so like when you see Donald Trump who
was not by any means hiding his
extremism and his ignorance and like he
was willfully put into office and then
like his VP Mike Pence is like
no-holds-barred extremist homophobic
racist etcetera down to Jeff Sessions
basically votes like all these people
have they haven't been slick about it
like they were not hiding [ __ ] hi
anything and well I like our cool with
that cool and so I think that when you
see just that happening now you see how
easily like something as Extreme as
what's going on the hammies tail could
take place because it really just boils
down to people not really grasping how I
have this guy I'm a couple decisions and
we can get to them yeah now one thing I
love about the show is how they'll just
be walking down a mart in the market and
I'll just see a body hanging hanging
that's like crazy but here's my question
for you from LA New York your coastal
elite period I I grew up in Orlando oh
sorry I'm sorry excuse me that's real
funny you got a lot okay yeah well
enough Confederate flags for everybody's
use me yeah because I met you in New
York's in my brain didn't ever you're
right Orlando's [ __ ] real as can be
I'm from Michigan reals can be do you
think real America is responding to this
show the same way because I live here I
more or less agree with the thoughts
here and the belief systems here and I
see the show and I go yeah we're not
that far away with Trump but are my
friends in Michigan thinking the same
thing are they I don't I don't know they
even interested in watching it I don't
know that's it that's what I'm asking
like I mean is a best [ __ ] the book
itself raised in 1985 yeah it's a
best-seller it's considered a new
classic right you can't really I mean I
can't imagine something becoming a
best-seller just from yeah Coscarelli
purchases yeah you know but I'm curious
if it's even being taught in schools and
like what that curriculum looks like
because you're right like I think and
that's why I like doing stand-up you
have to go to places like Corpus Christi
Kansas City etc etc because you get
tricked into thinking yeah that like LA
in New York or even Chicago in the bay
like you get just tricked into thinking
like we all think like this and then you
go to [ __ ] where was I recently in
Connecticut which by the way is not the
hotbed for progressiveness if that's
correct
I'm bed for [ __ ] country clubs and
squash yeah but also weirdly a mess City
entities as well yeah yes
and like our driver it was me a Roy Wood
jr. what I'm Roy Wood when we were doing
a hores okay ah Harrah's Casino okay and
our drive our like uber driver was like
yeah you know Trump looks great for 70
and we were I think and I just feel like
regardless of your politics yeah that's
not true
that's not true it's just not he can't
even stand like a normal human now she's
so wide all right go ahead no I was just
and so we did three shows no waited for
four shows yeah and um you know Roy and
I are both politically social commentary
yeah whop yeah comics and we walked a
couple folks did you we did walk a
couple folks so we felt good about that
well but I mean who you were booked I
hope because of it not because you walk
people because because we're a type of
comedy yeah but you see but you know
that casino crowds are three types of
people to the people who have tickets
this year round is going to come
regardless then it's people who wanted
to see you yeah well are fans of yours
Roy Wood jr. so show up or it's people
who just are in the casino and are like
well I guess I'll go on an issue or
their [ __ ] chicken sandwich was cold
and the decoders came over and said
here's two tickets to the comedy show so
you just end up there and you're like I
didn't come here to hear about your
talks about racism that doesn't exist it
it's good it's good to walk a couple
people because that means you're taking
a stance it's a strong point of view
hopefully it's funny but yeah there's
nothing like the unintended comedy
audience member who doesn't want to be
challenged because you're going to get
challenged yes
now hopefully your job our job is I'm
going to challenge you but it needs to
be funny and you're also laughing yeah
yeah that's not the hardest part would
be funny but we did I mean it was I just
bring it up because in response my
hammies - yeah you just see like just
because you think like this and everyone
around you things like this does not
mean that there's like a whole like
there's a whole other mass of people who
really don't was your driver white white
male I mean as white males again yeah
because it's interesting because the
night Trump won
here people and and we're still talking
about it but I think it's still it's
still interesting people were crying
here I mean like actually crying at the
Comedy Store yeah people were really
truly crying it was a weird time the
next night I flew to Erie Pennsylvania
and this man picked me up who had one
leg okay and he lost it in Desert Storm
and he was hungover from celebrating
Trump's victory and this was all within
12 hours it II to a man who's a veteran
that was like I'm so happy we finally
have and it's just like you forget about
this cut enormous place yes and stop
playing to just people that agree with
you it's time that's what I love about
stand-up comedy yeah I mean I had two
Mexicans that were Trump voters in my
crowd the other day and I have Sefolosha
on my mind and it made me little it
literally like go home and be like okay
you got a really tackle this for real
because I genuinely got stumped I didn't
even know yeah I got trumped as well you
go hey
so watch The Handmaid's Tale help
enjoying so what I want to do a man
before we get into your worst birthday
yeah which we will when is your birthday
by the way July 1st okay I believe I
should I wish I had all these memorized
who was July 1st Jimmy Pardo maybe I
think it was Joe pray no Joe pray no I
think we've got a lot of July I heard
rien yeah we all answer and are very
common cancers well if anyone knows Joe
pray no no he is a cancer here we go
Trump all right so this is uh this is a
worst birthday you can email me Oh is
your worst birthday Michael at Michael
Kosta calm or you can call leave a
voicemail nine oh nine five two worst it
should be flashing in front of your eyes
right now it's not we don't have that
capability
I know nine five to worst you can leave
a voicemail the more I get the more I
share with our celebrity guests so I'll
read this to you and I want to get your
feedback this one actually is from a
friend of mine named fielding ed Lowe I
didn't I I never knew that friends could
actually also email me what up Amanda
thanks amazing it's a snap in science to
snap instant snapping all right so this
is what she says and I want your
feedback on this so you got to pay
attention
you want you want to snap you I'm
listening okay uh hello Michael aka the
Great Gatsby of LA I don't know what
that is okay I guess because I'm
secretly in love with a woman and I'm a
multi-millionaire
that's none of that strip man my worst
birthday was my husband's Larry
50th birthday so the hello it doesn't
even have to be your own this is the
first time that has ever happened to man
okay normally it's your own but I kind
of like the chance that you send my the
worst birthday I've experienced with my
husband's 50th birthday he had the utter
hutzpah am I saying that right we have
like Jews here you're Jewish right Amana
he had the utter cuts but to rent out
some rat trap theater in Atwater Village
and hold 120 of his closest friends
hostage while he decided to tell for
long stories from his life okay one of
them was so depressing and long that his
one minor celebrity friend Mike O'Malley
you guys minors see do decrepit state
with - you said mine I don't know
Michael Malley hopped up and told a long
story about his own career just to get
the focus off his theater hostage
situation maybe some of your listeners
are thinking this wife sounds like a
real [ __ ] liquor she wrote it not me
we'll talk to me when your husband puts
on his best press slacks and then tells
a 28-minute story about 9/11 on his
birthday Lika this is still her worst
birthday and I like that he's wearing
slacks he pressed press packs Amanda and
he didn't even save anybody or jump into
the burning pile he just rushed down
there and stole some firemen gear and
pretended he was being useful I mean now
you sound like a [ __ ] licker
well why are you married to him I know
they have a funny funny they have a
great web series called bitter home
bitter homes that sounds right and it's
great yeah I mean I probably said it
wrong fielding but if you google it
that'll show up I will wrap it up I told
Larry I wanted to host a classy private
intimate dinner for him at Cafe Stella
but no he insisted and depressing the
[ __ ] out of every
buddy we know and I know everybody was
bored and horrified out of their mind
because they came up to me afterwards in
conspiratorial whispered man your
husband
hopefully Larry won't hear this what do
you think about that Amanda I think that
Larry I mean that does sound like some
wack-ass [ __ ] it also sounds like she
didn't even see it coming like I feel
like yeah you would know if your husband
had the propensity for this type of
[ __ ] unit sounds like she really just
had no idea well he's an actor
oh she's an actress so like you know
that that so she didn't but it's like
she didn't know it was going to be
performance yeah that's a great question
fielding hopefully you can let me know
or email me Michael Michael Kosta calm
but but they all showed up so just I
want to know how this is all so like
pitch like how was it promoted to the to
the family and friends right like hey
I'm doing a one-man show yeah birthday
or was it just like come by there's
drinks ah ha ha ha and Tails well that
that's interesting I mean I find us a
little opportunistic absolute to say and
I know Larry's a great dude but to say
like hey you have to come it's my
birthday and I'm going to run this
[ __ ] hour-long story by you guys but
then again I also enjoy when my father
turns 70 a couple years ago and he just
you know as seventy year olds do like
our boy Donald Donald Trump he just said
[ __ ] it I'm celebrating me and he got
the party he organized the foot he paid
for it all and he's like we're
celebrating me I just celebrated my
mom's 70th birthday last weekend like
that in Memphis okay my mother is not
from Memphis okay so what I've always
wanted to tell that my 70s and that's
why why were you in Memphis my mother is
from Grenada okay treyvion oh wow
so Memphis is like foreign yeah my mom
yeah so she like grew up listening to
Elvis and you know Otis Redding and
Rufus Thomas and all these artists my
mom is like a huge music fanatic so
Memphis has been this like hotbed of
music so that she's been feigning to for
like years she's like we have to go to
Memphis
just like what why doing low-key yeah it
was great it was great I mean I'm not a
big I I'm not a big music person but the
history of this city
Elvis live there I slam it Graceland is
we didn't go to great plan that gives
you how much we're there for three days
we went to like six museums Wow this is
Memphis is also where Martin Luther King
was assassinated
I need a museum out of the hotel it's
not a functioning hotel anymore no so
Lorraine hotel and it was also one of
the only like black owned hotels in
South yep so like you know when people
were traveling with like people
traveling they could stay there during
segregation and and then they have like
the the Blues museum and then have like
this rock and soul museum who else was
there with you and your mother
my mom and my aunt your and myself and
we like that's nice it was it was
designed it was my mom was like we're
doing this we're doing this because this
is what I want to do I like I mean I
like that I also look listeners three
people what do we always say be with a
small group of people that love and care
about you and lower your expectations
lower your accent you'll have a graver
yeah it's true
lower your expectations I have never
been so impressed by a Bass Pro Shop in
her impressive who they had an alligator
they had two Gators really in the Bass
Pro why we are there because it says
giant pyramid and the minute you land
guys like you're gonna go to the bass
pro shop motion everyone and and by the
way also uber in Memphis it's everyone's
first day Oberyn right right like all of
your uber drivers don't know what
they're doing yeah you either have like
uber drivers who are like vintage uber
yeah like this is all you do and they're
like you got to go to the bass pro shot
to go to raka so they run it down I'll
tell you the parkings they tell you
everything or you'll have people who are
like oh yeah are you Humana do I need to
see ID is like oh you don't you know do
this why yes I had one shaker with a
parked across the street she was parked
across the street and I was like are are
you Fiona it was like yes mad yeah yeah
no you got to come to me yes this is
okay yellow cab situation so Memphis but
but you quite like my mom is 17 yeah
and this is what she wanted to do and
I'm really and Louie lowered the
expectations all week and we could walk
everywhere it's great the barbecue was
great it's great you know and Beale
Street the street that's the street the
street the walk down Beale Street they
just have music playing like literally
every it's like I'm I've been to South
by Southwest I have not been there
that's by Southwest is the same thing
it's like go coast venues yeah so every
single venue has a different music
playing and um but almost please unlike
Larry's birthday correct your mom didn't
have a [ __ ] hour hours of speeches
and I kept them to 15 seconds come on
mom yeah that's it this this makes me
laugh this is very much in LA birthday I
absolutely you know and LA yeah the only
thing that I may get I need to know if
they were programs yeah we'll find out
fielding email me where their programs I
need to Larry make programs they were
like story synopses III know Larry a
little bit I don't think he's the kind
of guy that actually was thinking I'm
gonna throw a birthday and maybe get an
agent out of it I think he was probably
thinking I want to celebrate me and I
got some interesting stories and let's
talk about it but who knows who [ __ ]
knows I know that are actually they're
[ __ ] crazy I'm like is this something
I mean I feel like as comics like we do
this all the time yeah so you can come
and catch my birthday fairly often yeah
tonight it is the belly room of the
Comedy Store but you know one thing I
will say that I'm happy about with
stand-ups is we have an outlet pretty
much every night actors they audition
for 50 seconds No thank you you never
hear about you can't date actors you
can't date actually hell no so we get to
actually have an outlet and an immediate
response I mean every whether it's
whether it's a good or bad one I feel
get yeah an immediate response to what
you've done and you can move forward you
can move forward and there's no
bullshitting that response you differ on
them yeah on the phone there you know
about the audition oh we loved him he's
great but I didn't get the part comedy
did you love me because you didn't
you're all on your phone yeah that's how
I found my way to stand out tell me
about it because my only been in stand
up for it'll be
three years Wow you're remarkably good
and comfortable for that period of time
out there thank you are for real yeah
because I spent so much time I mean I've
been a host hmm for a long time and I
was doing like best week ever and I was
doing funny [ __ ] you know just not in
that place but I was doing music for ten
years so I was like I'm on like q-tips
last album what and I was like opening
for the root when doing what kind of
music I sing and I rat here we go where
do we find that and for that stuff you
can use YouTube do you yeah I should
have done that she may be from gym
gymnastics Memphis I've had a life yeah
you got a lot we've had a life on this
show
yeah we are we've traveled Ennis started
with four hands and back here Institute
but I I one thing that I had like I had
to get out of music because I realized I
would never be willing to give up what I
would have to give up to get to the
success or consider success sure like I
looked at me I was literally at an event
and I looked at Beyonce and I was like I
just don't you don't know if you could
do that I don't know but I really would
I live I mean I know Beyonce and I was
like I can't like she can't be shooting
him and I love you I shadow who did it
and I was like I I did I did it I did
and I was like you know what I can't ya
see that and then you do too much of
sacrificing your you you and your
integrity and your personality and
that's another part personality part cuz
like at the end of the day like you as a
comic the best part is like it's all
based on you yeah and I'm somebody who
just really is good at being me you're
good at being you so I'm like okay can
we just do this yeah and also the best
part about comedy for the most I mean
listen there's people who have
definitely broke the algorithm but for
the most parts of meritocracy if you're
funny you can make some headway if
you're not funny though yeah you can't
and you I love you by all the Instagram
followers you want you still need to be
funny I love that there's only one
compliment yeah in standup yeah you're
funny I like that that's it there's no
like I liked your energy yeah you know
like with music you confront I have so
many ways of
telling you I liked your performance
without telling you I didn't like you
performance right now I liked your
energy the band was kindled that
lighting Rikyu was awesome yeah I loved
your transition yeah you know Oh like oh
you got one note Oh No Oh if somebody
came up to me after showing that I loved
your transitions I'd be like oh I must
have sucked
I've had to do it before yeah that is
tough and and I say we say if you really
are funny you're guaranteed some amount
of success now what level
well there's also being a hard worker
hard worker there's luck there's lot if
you are funny looks if you know if you
are funny you're guaranteed some amount
of success but if you're not honey
yeah there's no auto-tuning comedy no I
guess I guess the equivalent would be
hiring someone to write an act for you I
think that would be me yeah but you
still have to bill got to do it you
still got to do it and even then you
know I don't I mean there's hacky [ __ ]
that happens you know but there's hacky
people yeah yeah no that's the other
part of it it's like whenever I see
hacky [ __ ] when you get mad at first cuz
you're just like god I'll [ __ ] but
then you're like yeah but those those
the same people who voted for Tom
probably yes oh yeah or that is actually
how his brain works
what's hacky in music auto-tune I don't
sing singing over like not actually
singing like doing the over your own
vocals or something I just feel like
when you are auto-tune is a big one yeah
also like just making it more about like
image and less about like actually
creating like songs that have value like
you can't [ __ ] on Gaga because no even
though she's like this whole image she
also has like solid music she can back
it up so you're like okay I get it but
then you get these folks that come out
that are just like a they're just a
presentation you know but are you really
singing you like Miley do we like Miley
no no why not
I don't disagree with you but I don't
know enough about music to really feel
like I can form an opinion for me Miley
is somebody who like tries on styles you
know like and then she moves on to the
next thing exactly is like a black
person she's like
ride on like black culture he's like oh
like I'm not at work and I'm gonna I'm
gonna yeah Mike will made it and now
she's like talking and she's gonna be
referencing jay-z and my song says I
don't even know who that is right like
okay someone wrote that for you and it
sounded cool
that's what it feels like you know and
now she's doing this whole thing where
she's like yeah like I'm just past that
like I'm over and Beyond hip-hop I feel
like she has no and this strikes me as
the opposite of you she has no idea who
she is and so she's got to be this
chameleon and it probably comes the fact
that she was world famous at the age of
10 and well I was on a TV show when I
was 12
here we go and I can tell you like it's
a weird like I I think I came out normal
just because my mom is an or like my mom
is normal right but the other kids on
the show it was called my brother and me
I'm Nickelodeon hey and I'm the only one
who like quote/unquote made it really
like no one else and I was just a
co-star like I wasn't yeah yeah I was
like I was suppose to be on two episodes
it likes me so they wrote me into the
whole series but like I wasn't part of a
conception of the show but their parents
where are you [ __ ] nuts us and we're
just like really about like I'm making
my khalasar you know and I think I too
wasn't even about that life like I
remember being like can I go to
gymnastics like right I remember
fighting with my mom like do I have to
go to this audition because I'm supposed
to be working out the level tens today
and this is a big deal I was like just
can you shut up yeah but yeah I think
that sport likes you real humble it does
good you split that beam yup and it's
you're not important anymore I that's
what I always said like my kids will
always play sports even if they're bad
because you get cocky someone in the
locker room hit me in the face or
something else someone elbows it just it
keeps you humble but that's why and
watch me circle back here here we go
that's why I started playing tennis
filming because on two sides of things
like one we're in this business it's all
about like nose and yesses you have to
be allowed at the behest of other people
so it's nice to like be doing something
that has nothing to do no with any of
that you know and then - it's a work
and then and they do those tennis bodies
I'm looking more at the women but I've
looked at some of the men the tennis
bodies are nice I'm lean you lean gross
yes yeah my mom texted me and was like
the tennis is doing good like I'm lean
you notice the sundress when I came any
coming I know dress I know can't wear
without being a certain level of TV fit
here we go and and then the third thing
though is it just like keeps you it just
I like playing for it cause it's so
basic it's like either hit the ball in
but this and that saying that's it
that's it you know yeah it doesn't and
and it's it keeps you humble because you
you're also not amazing at it yet yeah
you know but it's humble without it
being soul-crushing I love track from
the standpoint of it's like hey work you
see this line we're going to start here
you see that line we're going to go
there who can hit any fastest tell me
about a worst birthday you've had July
first
so I have like two great and I'm trying
to think okay so I'll give you the first
one it's quick so I told you my mother's
from Grenada yep in the Caribbean yeah
um I was in Grenada with my mom for my
eighth birthday and I stumbled upon here
we go
birthday decorations okay so I'm like oh
[ __ ]
Oh like in the house you mean like in
her suitcase like you you look like oh
yeah okay because you were living in LA
till you're 8 yeah we were visiting and
you're visiting down there go we're on a
trip ok because like I would go for like
a whole summer sure and uh could be
worse
it could be worse at the time I was like
why now I'm like thank you because I
have two passports I'm never going to go
okay um that's true yeah okay yeah so I
see these birthday decorations I'm like
oh yeah it's happening I'm having a
party that's sweet your mom packed
birthday stuff and yes no no this is
that kind of person she still does that
better way yeah so I remember a day July
1st I'm just like alright yeah
something's gonna go down here we go
today I saw them I saw the decorations
something's going to go down like new
oonh you know as like kid birthday start
early yeah so like at noon I'm like like
what's going on
one o'clock I'm sorry Elaine oh yeah so
one o'clock no one's there
and your body's you by yourself I'm so
like the way that our house is in
Grenada it's like it's like three houses
that are connected so I'm in like the
front house
I know milling about it's happening in
the back house there's asli they'd like
concerted effort keeping me at the front
house like okay it's on it's awesome but
like no one's coming right so I know
that there's something hadn't been no
one coming so I go to the back and I
like I'm like oh like I act like I uh my
mom's like you know and she's like well
we're trying to have a birthday for you
but no one has shown up yet oh and I'm
just like oh okay well you know like
what it okay
so I wanted like whether it's just wait
a bit four o'clock oh I'm in the front
house you're eight this is my eighth
birthday four o'clock I'm sitting on the
front veranda and my uncle without
stopping yeah just pass it through a
path of through and says the potty bust
and keep it moving the party bus is West
Indian for if this is a fail like your
party fell through and honestly like to
this day I'm still scarred by him saying
that now here's a happy ending yeah in
true West Indian fashion yeah five
o'clock everyone shows up are you
serious as if this was the prompt yeah
all right time my uh culture is that the
culture yes
we're just everywhere that late to chill
man that late yes they're either very
late or very early if I wanted it either
way hosting a party is impossible it's
not to get the food right it's
impossible and so and like it ended up
being a guy pictures on the twenty five
kids from the neighborhood like that
might my cousin showed up in this like
gown she's like a fashion show right
it was amazing but for this but you had
never I will never forget that panic for
those four hours as a kid for hours
extremely long Tommy John Aegon's worst
birthday and I forget what year it was
as maybe 11 or 12 but they threw a big
party for him and they got the big Pizza
Hut pizza and he just tells about
standing in front of his apartment
watching cars drive by and no one ever
showed up and to this day he won't
celebrate his birthday
people I mean I think I think ever lose
it the ultimate the the biggest fear for
all humans is rejection absolutely and
there's nothing more feeling rejected
than trying to celebrate and no one
shows up having a Memorial Day party
yeah I had one last year it was packed
like a dick I'm sure I'm I still anxious
ya hear that I'm still like and you
think it's because of this age it's
always it's always because I hear my
bitch-ass uncle a funny thing walk in
the fiery bus device like oh we'll keep
you humble too I remember the glasses
yeah and it but it wasn't it just
everybody's frown everybody showed up
late huh
but it was so late so what could you
have to think I'm waking up at 7:00 a.m.
I'm yeah so it's a whole day of just and
I'm an anxious person okay I'm just like
go to this day and the other birthday so
wait how are you going to how are you
gonna I think our listeners would would
would be curious to learn how you're
going to guarantee that people will show
up to your Memorial Day party I mean I
would do to getting yeah I send I send
save the dates physical we'll just email
but like tow and also I text nice so
Texas way more personal than an email I
agree and it sounds to me this is the
key I think that mean that you maybe you
just do naturally you're you're way
ahead of the game I mean you're not
doing this Tuesday now for Monday this
has been probably people been notified a
month before yes they have yeah that's
also really key everybody give it some
time so like my birthday is July 1st yes
I started planning my birthday in March
well because I wanted to do a getaway
good and people especially
la are the flaky like on his
[ __ ] of and here's the other
thing the other way to help is like when
people know that they can't get their
money back
yeah right for sure dupatta mean that's
he needs your check we need your deposit
yeah so for what get away what are you
doing yeah we're going to Palm Springs I
rented a house go me and my six
homegirls make sure I'm available and
everyone is confirmed yeah
has given me their money yeah it has
been made very clear that this cannot
get you can't get your money back you'll
still get some people that won't I bet
but you're gonna have enough you get six
girls a nice let's kill it's me I say
it's a good time that's gonna be a good
time it's a good time it's like three
it's we go there on Friday night with
their Saturday Sunday we leave Monday
morning no strings is really fun it is I
know it's such a and our house that we
got is like [ __ ] major everyone has
like everyone's tasked with bringing an
activity it's going to be a fun time
your organizer [ __ ] but you are
organizing [ __ ] I am and and and listen
my other home girls like told me like
they're like you have to make sure that
everyone knows that you can't go back
out what you have to go and I was like
you're right and the key though is that
a certain level of adulthood you also
like want something to do yeah don't
want to have to think I agree so like
two of my girls were like asking me is
this confirmed yeah cuz I'm there my
plans now yeah exactly no I love that I
love when someone says we bought we
bought you two tickets to the haunted
house and it's like BAM we're done
here's money thank you for organizing
the whole night I don't have to think
about him I know yeah that's smart play
what's your other worst birthday this is
and that's what I texted you yeah yeah
in capitals yeah and then you text me
lol what's just a waste of text Amanda I
just you know it's tone you don't know
my tone
I don't know your tone so I had to give
you lol tone yeah um 33 damn how old are
you you don't even look 33 I'm 35
I turned 33 it was good loss two years
ago yeah oh I love it already tell me
all about it so
oh I was living with a boyfriend nope I
had a boyfriend living with me okay does
that important yes it is yes okay so
apparently it's looking real important
it's very important to denote that this
person was living with me okay rent-free
oh I underst excuse me I thought that
was a power play no that's legit yeah I
was your it was your play yes and he
moved in - yeah and I in my youthfulness
so wait I'm 35 34 no it's 32 it's 32 -
so I and my I got a late bloomer no like
I didn't like I didn't learn I'm still
figuring guys out sure
so this was one of those like learning
situations where you're like oh never
[ __ ] again right okay but at the time
you're like well what he would I would
he gives me in companionship I can't
like at whatever sure so he's living
with me and he we'd been together a year
so he had spent my 30s
what are you la New York New York so he
had spent my 31st birthday with me and
we had a blast like we had went to
Orlando he got me tickets to the Harry
Potter [ __ ] like I mean yeah it was what
he's doing white guys black guys whoever
white guys never date me they never say
I'll have a joke on that challenge I've
heard that you do not like to talk about
racism and sexism and [ __ ] so we would
never let go for real um but that's like
out that's outside like to talk about
that stuff I love talking about that
stuff he says as a white male I feel
like you probably get bored with being
blamed well that's what I mean it's I
feel like I don't gain anything I can
all I can do is say the wrong thing I
feel like if I were a minority it's a
little more I don't know it's just all I
can do is screw up that's not true
you know I know but that's how I feel
and I think that's probably how a lot of
[ __ ] white males feel and and
uneducated white males they make it even
harder failed that and then [ __ ]
voted for our president
so yeah that's the platform based
exactly and and I feel stupid yeah
they're like stop giving
my job's all the [ __ ] robots you know
it's like no your job is obsolete sorry
you know anyways yeah okay so I don't
know how we got into this I never know
when white guys are hitting on me I
never know like when black guys are on
you it's very clear because they're
[ __ ] full-on they're just very direct
yes it's what's up what's up that means
they're hitting on you whatever like can
I offer you a warm beverage
I don't know that this tea means you
want to [ __ ] I didn't know it means they
want to [ __ ] with white guys are talking
to you and there's not microphones and
cameras and it means they want to [ __ ]
even if there are microphones and
cameras what happened to have headphones
fell off so yeah I understand but maybe
it's easier for you to read of black
males advancing I'm more attuned yeah
well you know and so and although it
just for the record the white guys would
have hollered at me weren't like the
best of the bunch and there's always
like a see like the ones who have been
clear it's always like a seediness to it
that I'm just like I think you you
thinking ooh like exotic alright I don't
know what she is well that excites me
you know and I'm just like yeah whatever
okay interesting okay this was a black
guy and he uh was evident in his library
shed he's probably still at that point
is life we doesn't know what he's doing
garlic no I don't date comics literally
like a bottom line there goes a hard
line rule yeah I can't do it I got you
we're too crazy I got you
we ride once okay and he broke up who
was it you tell me I was [ __ ] broke up
is not even a fair word we started
seeing each other and he ended it via
text with a peace sign emoji oh [ __ ]
nice play buddy nice play Roy Wood and
that was the end of that and it was just
like I can't even yeah it's happening
it's too it is a palace a comics are
rappers with no money yeah that's about
right it's the same level of like
machismo
and arrogance it's like the consistency
of money well that's that's good because
you know I used to date rappers because
I was in hip
sure though I've lived that life like
I've done it you need you need it you
need a you need a good white guy but
let's go let's get into this right yeah
this guy he's living with me and the
first birthday was great and I really
genuinely don't understand what it was
about this birthday that he was just not
[ __ ] here for him and so the morning
of my birthday I remember he had like a
production job he was like peeing or
something so he like got up right
he got up that morning left at like 6:00
a.m. and I got up like three hours later
I thought maybe there'd be like at least
a car hours are allowed I got to work
but it's your day right got you nothing
oh so I'm like come on bro huh but then
I am such a cockeyed optimist and I'm
like oh there's a prize don't come later
I'm going to work early he's gonna
figure it out yeah anticipation you know
so I go throughout my day
don't nothing what they look what day of
the week was it this was like a weekday
right it's like it was a Thursday okay
it was a Thursday good to know go about
my day and that night we were going to
the club because my publicist at the
time was like oh like you can celebrate
they want to give you a table and
bottles you might as well just go get it
pictures why not and I'm like it's my
birthday okay yeah by the white belt
this is what [ __ ] clubs do for women
on the remember we had Andrea Lowen here
from Playboy she's like they just would
pay me to go drink at this color my
birthday it's like Jesus Christ that's
why I literally that's what it was but
this has got to end - when with the
quality doesn't it well guys get that -
do they yeah
well I've no one's ever [ __ ] said
that to me pal I mean yeah OSHA pel
that's right
Helen I gets weekend similar treatment
treatment no I go throughout my whole
day I'm sitting in the makeup room at
best week ever it's now 5:30 sale and I
get a text from him and I'm like oh here
comes it says what are you doing okay
w-why be WY ideas now how you spell it
oh not even that was the text that was
at a green letter three letters so I'm
like I'm he has had no acknowledgement
of your birthday now family
I am at best week ever and he's like all
right that was it I was it I so now I'm
like okay this is crazy I get home I'm
sitting on the stoop talking about
homegirl he comes out the door and like
what are you doing I'm like I'm talking
to Stephanie he's like you talking [ __ ]
about me right now I'm like actually yes
[ __ ] shoot about the fact that it's
9:30 and you have yet to wish me happy
birthday today and he's like whatever
goes inside I come inside I'm like are
you coming to the club with me or not
it's like of course I'm coming to the
club I put on my dress he's like is that
what you're wearing
I'm like what is happening why is it
being fit to do I have no idea
we go to the club you know you're
looking good I 32 do it up three dudes
walk up that clearly are in the NFL so
it's one NFL player and his two cronies
so they walk that and they're like
walking towards us and I'm just like why
are these men walking towards us but
then my boyfriend like daps them up I'm
like horde what do you dude he's like oh
they're hanging with us tonight oh [ __ ]
no we're doing business together
what business yeah you're a PA what
business well it starts to get shady
maybe so now I just get shady long story
short we go in the club they sit in my
section they drink all of my liquor do
you understand yeah they're pouring you
know like if you're in someone else's
section like you're you're respectful
with the rationing yeah so you're gonna
have like a vodka and sprite or you know
you're gonna chat with the birthday girl
for a while you're going to be nice to
her and be warm to her and maybe she's
like help yourself yes yes these guys
are pouring full glasses of vodka on the
rocks
who are these [ __ ] and just down in them
then they start smoking weed in a club
in New York and I'm like yeah so I'm
like you can't do this but I just saw a
bouncer get someone else out like you
can't do this I say this to my man he's
like yo chill out man I'm doing business
with ya I'm doing business with these
guys
I don't give a [ __ ] if you're [ __ ]
these guys yeah yeah get them out of my
section and you're like man you just
don't know how to be cool fine I'm not
the cool sunglasses emoji right right
now they bring a cage
they bring a cake Kosta these guys ate
my cake
oh [ __ ] they drank your booze they ate
your cake they're hanging with your
oi and my man is literally like lounged
out on the banquette like he's posing
with Asia and Llewellyn playboy it was
insanity and he's uh you standing your
place and that's why it's important to
me to note that it is important he's
saying it my legs are free and so at the
end of the night my publicist is like I
mean what you want to do you want to
just go she's like let's go toast by
ourselves
yeah so we are literally like standing
by the bathroom and she's like happy
bird and we toast and I leave this
[ __ ] there good I leave him there and
when did you guys break up 15 days later
on his birthday on his fur here we go
hey that's a strong woman you [ __ ] with
me i'ma [ __ ] with you
fifteen days later on his 30th birthday
and she got him on this podcast talking
about his worst birthday um everyone
since he's roped up with me broadly oh
man well I will keep in touch with him
no I mean he attempted you would attempt
to I was that was selfish of him those
dumb it went on the next day yeah the
next day I had a brunch
he was shitty at the brunch he's
probably mad he's probably little
jealous or mad that his girl was you
know getting attention or more
successful than I am or whatever the
[ __ ] friends were the culprit yeah cuz
those guys don't count but he's like
actual friends would tell him like she's
selfish like you know I got offered to
do a reality show and I told people I
didn't want to do the reality show
because they were like we want to do
your personal life and his best friend
said to me why would you stand in the
way of his opportunities right and I was
like wait what for it's not thinking of
me it's for me and he was like yeah but
he would be on the show and that would
be a launchpad for him so why would you
stand in the way of that for him I was
just like this is good in my life this
is weird
so those are my shitty birthdays um I
would I would you're very easy person to
talk to and with unfortunately we are
out of time you're the worst birthday
party person but where can everybody
find your information where would one
find Amanda Steele's information I've
made things very easy for you you can
just amanda seals instagram amazing
feels calm whoo yeah Amanda seals
Twitter s.e.a.l.s ladies and gentlemen
and apparently my Instagram stories are
a big hit
oh good well I'm going to I don't know
if I follow you on Instagram but I'm
about to
yeah people really come up to me in the
streets and there's really like legit I
only do I mean I'm an only child so it's
like not right for me to just be like
hey I'm talking to my camera but I'll go
I like really about it so if you want
some wisdom and some fun joke check out
Amanda's field on Instagram um I'm sorry
that your birthday in Grenada Grenada
Grenada excuse me I knew I was gonna say
that wrong I'm sorry that it started so
late okay but I do think you've used
that emotion to advantage as life has
progressed it has and I'm sorry that you
had the club party that guy was too
douche but maybe you know what now he
has to watch me on insecure on HBO and I
know that it kills him right so well I
also don't think yeah that's just that's
insecure on his part you're talking
about the show on HBO but I'm talking
about [ __ ] that's him being insecure
I know that's counting Amanda steals
thank you for being here today thanks
God I bye everybody
me holy [ __ ] we